[Musique]
nuit sans lunes ciel dégagée les
conditions idéales pour observer étoiles
et planètes dans cette coupole de
l'observatoire de Nice
elle est à l'opposition à la banque elle
est bien bien lumineuse
Mathieu konja observe la géante gazeuse
du système solaire Jupiter
voilà on voit Jupiter avec l'ombre de
Ganymède qui est en train de sortir du
disque
il pratique l'astronomie amateur depuis
l'adolescence
ça sert à comprendre comment est fait
l'univers
comment il évolue comment il s'est formé
comment il va il va évoluer comment il
va vivre c'est toujours extrêmement
instructif surtout à notre époque où il
y a beaucoup de d'obscurantisme donc je
pense que connaître un peu démystifier
un peu les étoiles l'astronomie je pense
c'est toujours très utile
avec ce vieux télescope manuel des
années 60 matthieu a subi sa passion
la même soif de connaissance a poussé
les agences spatiales américaines
européennes et canadiennes a investir 10
milliards d'euros dans un télescope aux
capacités révolutionnaires le JWST le
James webspace télescope il décolle de
Kourou à Noël 2021 et on voit ses
premières photos 7 mois plus tard
il montre l'étendue de ses capacités en
reproduisant les piliers de la création
cliché iconique pris par son
prédécesseur Hubble en 1995 on voit
qu'on peut rentrer plus profondément
dans le nuage parce que c'est un
télescope qui travaille dans
l'infrarouge et on voit donc beaucoup
plus à l'intérieur et on voit des
détails très fins stupéfiant c'est des
images stupéfiantes à la caméra
Pierre-Olivier lagage a travaillé 24 ans
sur Miri l'une des caméras infrarouges
du télescope
et lorsque le grand public s'émerveille
devant la nébuleuse de la carène
c'est aussi ce spécialiste s'extasie
devant le spectrographe de l'exoplanète
WASP 96B
toujours beaucoup de belles images avec
le vilois c'est alors c'est très beau
mais pour faire la science ce que va
porter le ST c'est surtout de la
spectroscopie ce qu'on appelle la
spectroscopie c'est à dire décomposer la
lumière et voir en effet des signatures
de molécules entre autres ça va être
vraiment le là où la physique va être
faite avec le génouest il peut étudier
les conditions de l'environnement est-ce
que il y a de l'eau liquide est-ce que
comment il atmosphère sur différentes
exoplanètes ces planètes hors du système
solaire on a déjà pu détecter de l'eau
de la brume des nuages et du dioxyde de
carbone du jamais vu
l'autre grande mission du James web
étudier les galaxies les plus anciennes
comme sur ce cliché
[Musique]
sur ces images là on va
la phase principale d'activité de
formation d'étoile et croissance Galaxy
dans l'univers
dans ces tâches de couleur floues Nicole
nesbadba voit du gaz sa vitesse son
mouvement un trou noir et des galaxies
qui s'agrègent
si je vous dis ce qu'il y a rouge là
c'est à la signature de deux galaxies
qui sont en train de fusionner et ça
vient des années des années d'études de
savoir à quoi ça ressemble mais c'est ça
aussi de la beauté de la science parce
que ça nous permet de
recueillir tous les informations qu'il
nous faut et de vraiment aller beaucoup
plus loin que ce qu'on pourrait voir
avec une image oui si c'était à l'image
quelcon que ça pourrait être un petit
enfant qui est la force
formidable outil scientifique le James
web a aussi une vocation politique le 11
juillet dernier Joe Biden en personne
dévoile la première photo du télescope
une cérémonie avancée de 24 heures
coupant l'herbe sous le pied des
partenaires européens et canadiens qui
ne sont même pas mentionnés
au monde que l'Amérique peut faire de
grandes choses et rappelé au peuple
américain surtout nos enfants qu'il n'y
a rien que nous ne puissions accomplir
rien que nous ne puissions accomplir à
l'Observatoire de la Côte d'Azur cette
mise en scène a fait sourire Eric
Lagadec ça permet à beaucoup de
personnes de se rendre compte que
c'était quelque chose d'important je
pense que le fait que ce soit Joe Biden
qui fait une conférence de presse pour
montrer ses premiers images je crois que
c'était jamais arrivé pour pour un
événement astronomique j'aime bien
parler de concours d'orbite c'est un
petit peu ce qui se passe actuellement
pour l'astrophysicien très actif sur les
réseaux sociaux chaque nouvelle photo
suscite l'engouement le James web pour
la NASA c'est un petit peu l'étendard ça
fait rêver les gens donc on fait rêver
les gens c'est justifie les dépenses et
je me dis qu'aujourd'hui il y a
peut-être des enfants qui vont voir ces
images et qui vont devenir les
chercheurs de demain ou les chercheuses
de demain et ça ça n'a pas de prix de si
on arrive à pousser des gens à aller
vers les sciences on vit dans une
société qui est face à des défis
scientifiques majeurs et pour comprendre
ces sociétés on a besoin de comprendre
les sciences et l'espace l'astronomie
c'est vraiment une belle porte d'entrée
vers la science vers la méthode
scientifiques va la compréhension des
sciences
[Musique]
un an après son lancement le télescope
spatial James web dépasse déjà les
attentes
initialement prévue pour fonctionner une
dizaine d'années il pourrait être
opérationnel plus de 20 ans
[Musique]